it's amazing speaking here because you
can't see anybody in the audience so
anybody anything you do cannot face me
so just be yourself it's all good I want
to talk to you today this morning but
first of all I want to thank you because
whoever was out partying yesterday
showing up this early is a sign of
dedication to the cause so that's good
we need more people like you I'm here
and I wasn't early in bed so it's good
it's not good but fair enough I want to
talk about JavaScript today and how to
become a more happy JavaScript developer
not a better nor the most amazing not a
rockstar developer not like a ninja
unicorn whatever we want to call
ourselves but just understand that
JavaScript has changed so much over the
last few years that it's just not the
same thing that we used to do and it's
not you're not falling behind you're not
as good other people are not better than
you all the time
it's just a matter of like that it grew
from a language into this massive
infrastructure that we cannot understand
all the things it's just impossible to
do humanly and I I got inspiration by a
great book that I found on google play
the other day
that's called it's it's just you
everything is not which is a list
of all beautiful things of all things
that we should be happy about and we
should be actually celebrating these are
great things that are on this planet
that we can use and it's the same with
JavaScript to a degree that of course
there's many things that we can complain
about but a lot of the things in there
are just true the way the same way they
were when I started with javascript in
1999 they haven't come better they
haven't gone worst it just changed a bit
so the title said it's five the five
ways to be a happier JavaScript
developer but I think I give you two
extras today because I love you that
much this this was a meme that was going
around for quite a while where you had
like the JavaScript book and the
JavaScript the good parts book in
comparison next to each other and it's a
pretty unfair comparison because
javascript the good parts talks about
the Douglas Crockford wrote about the
things that are great about the language
as a construct as a syntactic language
as a functional language the way we use
it whereas javascript the Rhino book is
basically everything that JavaScript
ever has
to do in every horrible environment
possible so all the the browser-specific
things all the non-standard
browser-specific things are in there so
over the years it's basically a memory
of all the horrible things we had to do
and people had to suffer through to get
to the JavaScript a good part so the
good part is actually what javascript is
to a degree nowadays I learned
everything from that javascript writing
a book in 1999 and I was I was so happy
when I wrote a chapter for there was a
tech editor of a chapter for it sadly
enough it was two chapter for XML and
JavaScript which is something you
shouldn't do but when you get the offer
to be part of that book that you learned
everything from you jump on it it's a
fun thing to do now the seven things I'm
gonna plow through here is that
understanding JavaScript is not a
language concentrating on the now
limiting our development environment
make it harder to write bad code getting
to know our tooling giving back to
others and muffling the noise that is
happening around javascript so let's
start with understanding that javascript
is not a language it is it is a language
is defined as a language but it's much
more than that and grew into something
completely different it is a lot of
things it is a it's far from perfect
that's what that's for sure I mean like
when you do like type off not a number
and it says number then you're like you
need a special kind of person to get the
head around that kind of thing and it it
took the date format from Java which is
not a good idea either because it hasn't
been updated in donkey's years
and so on and so forth it's everywhere
though JavaScript runs on everything
nowadays I mean you see people giving
coffee machine talks but they talk to
the coffee machine in JavaScript every
browser has JavaScript enabled and I
remember in flash was too cool thing and
Adobe was basically advertising with 99%
of the computers on this planet on the
Internet
half flash enabled well a hundred
percent of those have JavaScript enabled
it's up to the user to disable it and we
as browser makers made it much much
harder to disable it paint by now
because it's a developer thing to
disable it not an end-user thing it's
also free to use when I started with
JavaScript I loved it because I used the
text editor and I started writing
JavaScript and I use the browser and I
started playing in it I didn't have to
download or pay for or pirate a copy of
Borland C++ builder or whatever or an
IDE that I had to learn for four weeks a
text editor would do the job an
environment independent so I went from
my my Windows machine to Linux to Mac
and all of those JavaScript worked on in
all of these environments I could use
JavaScript in I didn't need to have one
certain environment a certain mobile
phone with a certain operating system
and a certain cable that they change
every year because they want to make
money of you but I'm not bitter about
this and this is off topic right now
it's really documented it's basically
you didn't need to buy a JavaScript book
it was good when you bought my book cuz
I was happy and I basically wrote it so
my parents would shut up about what I do
cuz I couldn't explain to them what I do
they don't know what computers are but
as soon as they had a book in their hand
they basically were happy and showed it
to people when they visited us so
everything we looked up in the past on
the on the internet was lost javascript
things I mean a dhtml drive and these
kind of things these copy and paste
things to do HTML days and everything
was on the web and freely documented you
didn't have to go through an extra
course to learn JavaScript and it's
instantly gratifying and that was why it
beat beat everything else that I wrote
before I used to write assembly then I
wrote Perl and in JavaScript I just
fiddle around with it I reload the
browser and like cool this thing is
already happening there's no build
process in between where my computer
goes for a coffee break for like 15
minutes and then I realized I forgot a
semicolon somewhere javascript
immediately runs in the browser and I
see not mistakes I made and it was great
for that the versatility of JavaScript
but it can be applied to and as many
many things means that there's diverse
needs so when I for example go for web
scripts that's what most people started
with JavaScript and then they didn't
understand and they use jQuery so like
how do I make that button blink or move
and I click on it okuu does this
javascript this is what it does then of
course we went for web view based
solutions like electron like slack most
editors out there are actually HTML
javascript or typescript JavaScript
based software running inside a
container that can be installed as a
native application on different desktops
then we have browser extensions which is
the which everybody loves everybody
loves extending browsers as a browser
maker I'm working on edge right now I
used to work on Firefox before
extensions are the bane of our existence
because they're the biggest security
attack point and also the biggest
performance problems for browsers but I
think the browser's became as successful
as they were because they were
extensible and writing an extension for
browsers also done in JavaScript web
based apps PWA
I'm gonna give I'm gonna go later on to
a meet-up here and also give a pdp-8
talk as well they're server-side
solutions note JavaScript started as
life script actually by netscape on the
server side before it actually went into
the browser but now we do a lot of stuff
in node on the server side and also on
the client side convertible two binary
formats web assembly is the big thing
you probably saw heard about blazer
yesterday where we tried to make c-sharp
happen in the browser so you can take
right in your crate code and turn it
into javascript with web assembly and
powering robots note bots are saying
that actually happening out there so
javascript works everywhere we even have
a package manager npm now so if you if
you go back to the pecco days of of perl
we now have that in JavaScript as well
it all goes in circles we always say
like oh the old stuff that you Debbie
don't want to do anymore we're gonna
repeat it in five years and call it
innovation it's quite fun how we work so
javascript is so much more now than we
ever expected it to be it it was just
this little language that I can make
interactive things on the web but it
became much more it's a standardized
language for starters the tc39 the ACMA
script committee is standardizing the
language and we finally have a language
definition not like what some browser
makers thing javascript is and other
browser makers saying what javascript is
and whatever microsoft thought when we
made when we made like most jscript
don't do that it's like we have a
standardized language let's make the
standard work it's also an ecosystem
like the whole npm and the whole node
environment is an ecosystem of
javascript where we we write software
much like we would in other languages
and we deploy software like we do in
other languages as well and it's a
community a big community of almost up
to big communities like to javascript
events every day at the moment but it's
something to dive into and get help and
to help
people in it as well as an opportunity
to do a lot lot with one language it's
always quite fun with versa it's just
JavaScript numb like well it's your API
written in JavaScript that I need to
learn it's that random end point it's
that random hardware that it runs on so
just JavaScript is always a weird thing
and it's a chance to cause damage
performance and safety because it's so
easy to learn JavaScript it's so easy to
deploy JavaScript and use it you can
make a lot of mistakes with it as well
and you can actually make a server that
is completely vulnerable much like you
can set up an Apache to be completely
vulnerable and sometimes I think we
underestimate that when we say we're a
full-stack developer and we put
something on the internet now I think we
it's time to relax though in a world of
options nobody can be an expert in all
of them if you're confused about what
note is but you like working in the
browser in JavaScript good for you
cool concentrate on that know the limits
of the other stuff appreciate what other
people are doing in the other in other
parts of JavaScript but you don't need
to know everything you can always learn
that as you need it when I worked as a
consultant or I worked in an agency
every product we made was a different
platform was a different programming
language was a different vironment for
two years I accumulated so much
knowledge that I completely forgot three
weeks later and this is also a truth of
our market that we should embrace more
now concentrating on the now is a very
important thing in JavaScript
I think worries of the past shouldn't
prevent us from creating when you're
like me and you get like these
flashbacks to Internet Explorer for five
Netscape 4 netscape 3 gold
communicator and these kind of things
that i had to use in the past I look at
the JavaScript and I'm like ah this is
bad we should optimize what am i doing
this is dead this environment doesn't
exist anymore and nowadays evergreen
browsers this is fine don't don't let
the EDT worries of the past stop you
from playing with JavaScript or even
more
let's stop telling new people coming to
JavaScript that it's terrible because of
problems we had 20 years ago this is not
helping anybody and it's actually just
us showing off like I went through that
pain I want to get something back you
won't get something back just be happy
with what you have to
days on the other hand it can be also
depressing to focusing exclusively on
the new and cool like if I have my mic
by Chrome Canary running and my insider
windows build everything is beautiful
and everything is cool and our end users
that are out there and basically will
never see what I'm doing
one thing that depresses me a lot as a
browser maker right now is that every
time we create something incredible and
we standardize it the bad people of the
internet are the first ones to use it I
still don't know any sensible use case
for web Bluetooth but it's used already
by malicious ads to actually fingerprint
computers so by the time we wrote
something out and we get developers
excited people already found a way to
exploit it and as few talks about this
here actually and it's kind of
depressing so I think being on the
bleeding edge is great but we shouldn't
we should always understand that our end
users aren't there yet so work towards
that but don't expect it from anybody
out there because you're not building
things for other developers unless you
build things for developers and good for
you if you wanna know anything about
JavaScript and look it up mdn web talks
at developer mozilla.org is the place to
go this is not because I worked on that
thing when I worked in Mozilla but
because we shut down all the Microsoft
web technology documentation and put it
on mdn as well because we realized this
is the resource that's alive that people
are maintaining that is understanding
understanding has code examples has like
support things in there which browser
supports what information this is the
one place to go where you don't go as
w3schools because you're an evil person
if you do that and you send it out to
people because it needs to die in a fire
but that's just a slight feeling that I
have about this but this is a great
resource to learn everything about the
web and I'm very happy that Mozilla
exists and actually makes it and it took
us three years to merge these two
because of lawyers not because of
technology because the operating said
he'd CMS that runs it is totally fine
with our data going in there as well
Google puts says stuff there Samsung
puts their stuff there everybody works
on the wood works on the web maintains
this and we used to have the web
platform dot-org before as well and ever
gonna shut down as well this is now the
one resource another thing to look at
the time is can I use comm so this is
why you see parts of JavaScript and what
the support in different browsers is
what a screen is good what is read is
not good and sometimes there's a yellow
and there's full explanations what the
yellow means and there's also links on
the bottom through to the specifications
and demos and polyfills and so on and so
forth
so if you wonder about using something
can I use comm is the place to go now
what I like is right now is that we can
limit our development environment and
I've done that lately a lot because I'm
kind of tired of like every conference
that I am talking about this Trinity of
web development what I mean by that the
first one is the editor we have got all
these like handbags out fights about
which editors the best one which one to
use so in editors we actually we code in
editors that's well that's what they're
for but we're also we tweak themes so
every new every week there's a new theme
that you should use or you're not a
professional developer ligatures encode
encode funds if you don't use that you
know the professional bit developer oh
you use white background I use black
background you're terrible person or you
can also use a black background I'm the
just shut up because let's let's let's
just code and use the thing and do
something good in there we it's also
where we make spaces and tabs like
animals the second part is then once we
coded the things where we actually
deploy it and why we packaged it and
where we make it run is in the terminal
the terminal in this case is of course
on the Mac it's your it's your I term -
or it's your terminal built in or your
that is H on my Windows machine I'm
using Ubuntu right now and I'm going to
Cali for a few fun things as well so we
got all that all the terminals in all
the operating systems for you that's why
we do version control let's go see
that's where CVS are almost said that's
what get comes in and as for github
comes in and there we also run build
tasks and there we also deploy and there
we also tweak seems that's another thing
like everybody has to have seen for the
terminal and we write long blog posts
and give talks about how to tweak your
terminal to be more effective why we're
actually not finishing code because
we're spending too much time tweaking
our terminal the last thing is the
browser
and the browser is of course where we
see the stuff we debug in the browser
the everyday browser has developer tools
that are immensely cool I mean I'm
working with all the other browser
makers and what we do in developer tools
that the kind of depressing thing is
like you see all these talks about what
developer tools can do and then you see
the the under the hood specific stats
what people are really using about two
or three things of the 600 that we have
in developer tools so there's a lot of
like oh you could use this but people
just don't where we check in which weak
outputs and where we audit so all the
thing in the browser and testing in the
browser is a very important thing now
the problem that I have with this
Trinity is that we also annoy people
with log messages like DDD life sites
out there that still have log messages
in there it's just very unprofessional
very dangerous as well my problem is
that this is a lot of duplication and
multiplication with choice so we got
very we keep ourselves super busy by
tweaking all of these three things by
telling everybody oh there's a new
terminal out you should be using that as
you editor out and I actually don't want
to jump between them all the time I
don't want to just write CSS and then
have to go to the terminal and build it
and then have to set up my node server
to do the build with the packaging and
whatever and then go to the browser and
edit it again why don't we do that in
one environment and why don't we dumb
gonna have a half that way much more
time to concentrate on our code and this
is what I've been doing lately a lot so
tooling is actually starting to overtake
our historically grown Trinity these
things starts to merge again so good
editors actually consolidate features to
avoid context switching so you don't
need to leave you editor to do the two
other things like the github thing and
the building thing and the the audited
the auditing thing now I don't care what
editor you use as long as it's Visual
Studio code because I'm working on that
one and it's just gorgeous I mean it's
like it uses github a packaging and
install mechanism it uses Google's
browser and it uses Microsoft's Visual
Studio intellisense stuff so all the
people working together on this open
source project written in typescript
which is just nuts if you think about it
so here's code if you don't know it it's
open source it's cross-platform its
hundreds of extensions for everything
that you ever want to have or not have
it's highly seem evil so yeah you can't
complain about white backgrounds black
backgrounds pink backgrounds whatever
you want to do it's got built-in source
control support so when I teach people
about web development these days instead
of just going to the terminal and so
like and here's how I deploy it's like
okay steed you see that you just save
this and now it says there's a merge and
green sing click on that type of comment
and it sends it off to the server and
it's already available how cool is that
don't have to jump to the terminal and
get people afraid of Deepti green thing
that they don't want to understand it's
got a built in terminal so under your
editor you got the tram allows you don't
need to switch to the other app there
and it integrates into build processes
it actually is written and extensible in
typescript which is nuts to think about
like when you write the editor that you
use for writing typescript in typescript
it's quite bizarre and it straightens
and lightens teeth with repeat use so
more you use it and it's also possibly
good against hair loss and it's gluten
free or macrobiotic so there's these are
all reasons why you should be using
Visual Studio code and I love these
little things that you see like via
Scott's autocomplete is amazing I get
like 60% of the letters right or what I
want it still guesses the right thing
Rick lists odd request options I can
roll my face on the keyboard and still
be close and I love this this is what
editors should do for me I should not
have to know which upper case lower case
can locate staying that is I used to be
a PHP developer no I don't want to look
these things up because they're
different in every way and every
function name anyways so what they do
what you can do as well you can debug
node in it so if you have node running
and you want to write node you can just
say like debug tools in node itself and
then down and d-terminal in the built-in
one you can run your code and then it
goes into the breakpoint and your node
instance gets gets interrupted and you
can debug it there rather than having to
have to do it and determine all yourself
so you can stay in that environment and
see what happens and this is only
possible because we have like
virtualized headless browsers we have
like JavaScript itself is a runtime and
notice a runtime as well so you can
embed that into your editor you don't
need to do it in the terminal
burr : my colleague rotavator wrote a
great article core Visual Studio can do
that question mark where it explains all
these things if you want to go to so
instead of using your own machine why
not try online before I love that that
we instead of explaining in an email 50
times what I've done wrong and what I
should be doing just right at jsbin just
put it there and say like what am I
doing wrong and people can start editing
with you and showing you and forking it
and doing a copy of it and showing you
where the problems are and you don't
have to explain your code you just show
it to people and they help you
there's no of course code Peniel which
is a super inspirational thing for
creative coding kind of stuff and as
glitch comm which is up-and-coming and
it's basically allowing you to write
apps in the browser and deploy them onto
github immediately from the browser as
well so these things are great for
learning with each other and sharing
with each other via Scott now has a mode
now where you can code together with
other people life so that's quite fun as
well especially when you fight each
other over lines and stuff I like that
these things make it much harder to
write bad code I mean I love for example
when I use word and I write route wrong
it gives me these squiggly lines under
it and editors do these things now as
well and I love that we have them so
when you write JavaScript and you want
to have a stricter code you can actually
turn on the TS the typescript compiler
just by doing a comment above it saying
TS check and out of a sudden all the
things that are wrong in your JavaScript
or that need to be fixed get squiggly
lines under them and there's a little
light path next to it you can click on
and explains to you what you've been
doing wrong and how cool is that rather
than like having to know what I did
wrong or get some cryptic error message
like ie used to give me like undefined
is not defined and I'm not great I don't
want a philosophical browser I want to
have an error you sure you see what
you're doing wrong while you're doing it
and I wish more more people would
understand that linting to me is much
more powerful than debugging because I
find mistakes while I make them I based
on experience and consensus of many
others so I can't disagree with a lot of
the things a linter says but and
sometimes there's a good reason for it I
learned from explanations of lynching
results rather than getting random error
messages and
I install and configure or use built-in
linting so most editors have built-in
linting now but in essence what it means
I moved from knowing everything to
learning by making mistakes and as I
said before JavaScript has become so big
you cannot know everything any longer
and that's good I my head is full of
full of information what Internet
Explorer six and five and seven did
wrong
I want to purge this I want to get rid
of this but it's burned in there because
of the pain I had to go through and you
don't need to do that anymore all the
thing is another big thing lighthouse is
a part of the Google developer toolkit
for example and developer tools you can
already work before you go life you can
actually run it against like how PWA
ready it is how how good quality your
code is you can learn from explanations
of why these are mistakes you can keep
iterating until it becomes a second
nature so you don't actually make these
mistakes anymore and you have lynching
and validation tools that can be part of
your release process this is Sona well
if you haven't tried that one yet you
can come to the to the Microsoft booth
later I can show it a bit it's we're
working on that we have to change the
name again because of copyrighted or
whatever I don't know but basically what
it tells you put a URL in there and it
shows you everything that you've done
wrong in terms of accessibility in terms
of security in terms of standard
compliance and cross browser support so
you can do this on the command line as
well as part of your continuous
integration and get like a unit test
pack or you can just do it in the
browser to play with your website from
time to time so getting to know our
tooling to me is the super power that we
have right now that we should be
thinking about more it's true that the
tools have become much more complex
people looking at like ad developer
tools in chrome nowadays to like the
alert that we used to do is like oh my
god I don't have time for that but it's
really like sharpening the saw like
learning it the first time and
understanding this thing makes you much
more powerful in the near future it
gives you superpowers and insight how to
build great solutions the biggest thing
if you if you're still doing it please
move away from console.log and use
breakpoints instead because then you can
jump from node to javascript in the
browser and whatever easier and you get
full insights and we don't get these
random console log messages in life
sites any longer it's just a very
unprofessional unprofessional it's just
a very lazy
way of debugging well we got so much
more better tools with breakpoints
nowadays now once you're happy with
JavaScript I think it's time to give
back to others and to take part in the
JavaScript community you could help
document things even if you don't want
to code help a good travel script
project and fix some typos write some
explanations these kind of things and
it's also great for your CV because
people look at get up and out of a
sudden you're part of that JavaScript
library that everybody loves great help
clean up and send pull requests publish
your own work as open source that's of
course mean it's scary but it's also
great because I get run over by bus my
stuff a lot my stuff survives and enjoy
meetups and events you do right now I
guess so you can enjoy meetups later on
as well and as I said one every day at
the moment and help by example not by
telling people what they should do here
so like you're not a professional
developer if you don't do this it's just
horseshit I'm very tired of this it's
like I've been 20 years in the IT world
and I've seen everything come and go and
what is a professional developer is
somebody who's flexible enough to see
that younger developers have great new
ideas and you should listen to them and
empower them and not tell them this is
how never worked it will never work in
the future either now there's a lot of
noise around JavaScript there's lots of
stuff happening and you think you're
falling behind if you don't know the
things and not everybody cares about the
nuts and bolts or ice endless time to
invest so instead of explaining people
like why did I've done things wrong and
which JavaScript environment is the one
that they should be installing just help
them with their problem and let them be
on their merry way and then find the
next mistake themselves don't make the
dependent on us the expert it's easy to
get tempted to sell people your
experience as a best practice and the
best practice to me is found it's never
defined a best practice differs from
project to project from environment to
environment what's the best practice in
node is not necessarily a best practice
in a mobile JavaScript application or in
a browser extension so these things
whenever somebody says that's best
practice time like well how has it
proven itself which which department
which company which which product became
much more successful by being a best
practice otherwise it's just a this is
how to do it rather than like proving it
to people
great example find the largest item in
the array that's the kind of horseshit
questions we give people in interviews
so back in the days when I started with
JavaScript I probably would have
something like that largest an array let
temp zero loop over it and then find out
if if it's bigger than the last one and
the biggest one gets stored in the temp
and then I return the temporary and then
of course I remember that doing the
array lengths iteration on every reading
on every iteration of the loop was very
slow in Internet Explorer 6 that's why
it's a terrible way of coding so what we
do instead is like we also cache the
length of the array in all and then do
the while loop backwards over it because
it doesn't matter which order we're
going it through and find the temp thing
there then you actually start thinking
about like hey there's don't des native
options for that I don't need that if
statement that actually sued us T which
one is bigger than the other there's
math max for that so do the math max
array all and temp to get that one then
I start actually looking at the
documentation of JavaScript maybe
there's something you can use and you
find out that it's a race sort and
reverse zero does the same thing and
then you look at the newer versions of
JavaScript and you find out that you
have a method called mass Mac star that
this is three characters and not the
type of graphically correct ellipses
pisses me off but that's a different
thing now the question is which one is
the best and the answer is of course it
depends questions like who is writing
the code where does it run how clean is
the data we deal with what horrible old
environment need would need support who
will maintain it how likely is it ever
to change how will it be used these are
all the questions about like what is the
best part of code that we do so we
cannot just say like this is the way to
do it so validating and triaging is a
skill that I think more and more people
should learn let's not feel bad if not
everything in the chess world excites us
if somebody gets talks to me about the
newest package that they did to do that
thing and I'm like good for you I I
discovered a few JavaScript patterns
I've got people coming up to me and say
like oh my god you're Travis keep
pattern safe me that's life and did this
number oh that's what it does it's
amazing how much more intelligent people
are that are using my things than I am
and I love that that we in this world
that they can be excited about it I
don't need to be any more not everything
hot and cool is ready to replace what
we're comfortable
so if somebody writes a loop with with
it with an all iteration on every
iteration that's fine because we
optimized the JavaScript engines to do
that better nowadays it doesn't manage
make out if it doesn't make your lives
easier it is okay not to use it hype
moves fast and forgets fast you don't
need to use react on everything view on
everything
todo on everything jQuery on everything
if you don't have time to to triage it
and to understand it then probably it's
not for you and it's totally ok to write
the thing that you've done you can use
an a five-year-old solution if it makes
you happy and you release things we're a
delivery mechanism we're there to build
things so people can do things this is
what we're for it's not to make us happy
we get paid so we're not happy no we get
paid so we're happy I don't even though
we're not necessarily happy with what we
have to code let's be excited but also
be ready to give it a man like when
there is a drama about something cool
and you have no opinion don't jump into
that threat don't be that person that
says like oh I gotta be dad cause the
cool Talk kids are talking about it I
don't care anymore
projection isn't good what makes this
effective can be very subjective like me
being now inside code only is happy for
me other people who would want to work
for 100% in the terminal and open up vim
in another in another tab fine for them
as well it makes sense to talk about our
success so instead of telling people you
should be using this tell them I use
this it makes me successful and happy
maybe it works for you as well here is
why it made me successful here is how it
measurably made that project better and
made our developers stay longer in the
company and not leaving in these kind of
things it makes less sense trying to
force others to do the same as you do
and new approaches lead to new happy
paths let's not discourage people from
finding theirs so as I said if a new
engineer comes up to me and says like
everything I do is I'm like ok
I used to be you fine give it give me
give me what you have tell me show me
what you got and then like ok cool this
makes sense I understand where you're
coming from now let's not kid ourselves
about the bleeding edge though that the
amazing new idea of today often becomes
the problem of tomorrow like jQuery UI
is in many many websites it's very very
slow also security problem in some and
non upgraded versions and so on and off
both production code moves less fast
than we think so every time we think
like oh this library is two days old and
we should be using it you probably not
be able to roll it out in an enterprise
company our end users aren't guinea pigs
or canneries they actually rely on our
stuff to work so when we want to do
something cool that it's like
experimental and might blow up in their
face we didn't help anybody and it is
the bleeding edge make sure you have
enough blood to give so if you're
actually on the bleeding edge you have
to have time you have to have time to
test things and give feedback it's a
great place to play but it's also
something that costs a lot of time so
let's make a great community out of
JavaScript let's be the people we'd like
to have met when we started not the
arrogant people that told us we're doing
everything wrong let's be kind let's be
understanding why people make mistakes
and why people do things in a certain
way a certain way let's be supportive to
new people and let's allow people to
learn by making mistakes and letting off
steam so of course they're gonna be
angry at things and say that Microsoft
is and Google is and to view
Jess and react.js I shouldn't let them
ran for a while and then like okay how
can I help you what is really the
problem that you're having here let's
not get lost in pointless drama this is
that we have a limited amount of time on
his earth
and we have a even more limit at a time
to make our mark in this environment so
let's not get into drama but actually be
happy about what we have and javascript
is a friggin cool thing to work in so
thank you very much
[Applause]